pour l'Étoile sportive auaisienne c'est
jour de match à la défense Marvin serré
32 ans dont plus de deux décennies passé
dans le club effectivement je suis
arrivé tout gamin et et aujourd'hui je
suis un homme donc du coup en tout cas
j'essie donc donc ouais ouais c'est
c'est c'est ça fait beaucoup de temps
c'est mon club de cœur c'est le club où
je suis depuis 22 ans donc c'est un club
qui qui m'apporte beaucoup et et donc
j'essaie de leur rendre en retour malgré
mon grand âge donc non non c'est c'est
un super club pour moi c'est un club
familial avec des valeurs donc c'est
tout ce qui m'importe certes le ballon
n'est pas oval mais pour beaucoup ici
Marvin est un véritable pilier de
l'équipe j'ai besoin de lui dans un
groupe c'est quelqu'un qui va motiver
qui va voilà généralement même les cris
de guerre à la fin de chaque match c'est
lui qui a l'initiative de tout ça donc
c'est vraiment il fait vraiment un
comment dire on a un électron on est
tous autour de lui vraiment dans dans
cet état d'esprit ouais rien d'étonnant
donc à ce que l'enfant du pays a été
choisi pour pour incarner son club dans
l'illustre album Panini celui-là même
qui fait rêver les amoureux du foot à
travers le monde depuis plus de 60 ans
avoir sa propre vignette au côté de star
tel que Kylian Mbappé une expérience
hors du commun jamais un jour je me
seraai dit oui j'y serai alors peut-être
dans un rêve d'enfant dans un rêve de
devenir footballeur professionnel comme
tout comme tous les enfants mais mais
sinon non jamais il y a beaucoup de
fierté de pouvoir rendre tout ce que le
club m'a pu porter durant toutes ces
années et beaucoup de joie oui parce que
c'est pas anodin mine de rien et puis
c'est quelque chose dont je me
souviendrai toute ma vie séance photo
dans un studio parisien nouveau maillot
designé pour l'occasion un sacré coup de
projecteur qui donne le sourire à l'une
des premières supportrice du joueur ah
il est beaucoup plus beau en vrai mais
savinette est très très bien le foot
c'est plus qu'une passion pour Marvin
c'est je dirais presque une religion
pour le coup euh mais non c'est c'était
une vraie surprise et une une très belle
surprise une surprise qui permet de
mettre en lumière les clubs amateurs
antichambre des futurs prodiges du
ballonrond